voilà un bon voyage de jean-paul
rappeneau le soir mercredi
alors il vend
j'étais j'ai jamais mois dans la dans
les premières tout ça je vais pas trop
dans ces trucs là mais là mardi j'y
étais il y avait du lourd un dirait du
monde du vélo n'a
pas vu moi je suis retourné obligé de
regarder le film comme ça implique on
tousse on baisse la tête nature majesté
à côté de virginie ledoyen tout ça les
stars peuvent sans révision était
extrêmement applaudi et tous ses biens
ses premières je vais y aller plus
souvent moins il y avait un dîner après
il y avait un petit 10 mais alors
comment c'est bien l'allemagne avait pas
énormément d'amis beaucoup moins de
monde que dans la star là il ya les
privilégiés qui privilégie voilà j'ai bu
pas mal ouais c'était l'anniversaire de
rappeneau ça tombait bien tout le monde
était torch et à la fin vous étiez assis
à côté de qui virginie ledoyen à la si
vous quittez plus de femmes en face ne l
est pas venu à la projo iodine été
repéré à côté de moi rigolard et on la
connaît timide s'est planqué d'accord le
doyen ils se trompent pas et alors
pourquoi adjani était pas là pour jour
je crois qu'il était malade j'ai eu un
message dans la journée qui m'a fait
très plaisir d'ailleurs voudrait
l'embrasser va parler était complètement
aphone et elle n'a pas pu venir à cette
projection et depardieu pour y était pas
là charleville lisez
ligier lisait des poèmes je sais pas où
est dakar il a dû partir après en moto
en algérie mais je voulais que le film
était accueilli comme an plus tôt bien
plutôt bien j'ai l'impression et la
salle applaudit well as un talent très
très enthousiaste mais là je trouve que
rappeneau a réussi vraiment un grand
film c'est un gros film qui a énormément
d'ampleur et ce qui est incroyable c'est
que il a mélangé les tonalités le film
est drôle c'est un film pas l'historique
mais dans un contexte historique donc
c'est toujours difficile de parler d'une
époque en même temps il la traite par
des petites touches ya rien de lourd il
ya des images de paris désert on voit
des motos d'allemand
arrivée puis tout d'un coup malgré les
scènes de comédie dans le film en
derrière les acteurs principaux il ya
des gens avec leur valise etc puis ça
nous rappelle qu'on a un moment assez
grave il ya de l'amour d'attendre réseau
l'action et c'est drôle donc moins voilà
euros ils ont entendu il devance la
première télé que vous faites là sur ce
dossier la première télé que je suis dit
si tu viens vous en parlez bien normal
parce que j'aime l'art en général les
maires télé en road un peu le show tu
vois on se dit bon je trouve non mais là
il est vraiment c'est un film qui a de
l'ampleur que ça fait plaisir de d'être
dans un film comme ça en tout cas
laurent vous est d'aller le voir oui ça
m'intéresse je vois ce que font les
confrères
elle leur offre un film et je sèche et
on est devant avec ya que moi qui n'ai
pas tourné il ya un truc que je trouve
assez désagréable orange préfère-t-elle
dire c'est que tout paris a tourné dans
ton film sauf moi quoi toi tu mérites un
film qui sera le prochain